Morgens auf Hof Butenland.
Rosa, Frederik –
Essen!
Karin Mück ist keine Bäuerin,
sie pflegt Tiere.
Schwein Frederik ist von einem
Tiertransporter in die Freiheit gesprungen,
Rosa stammt aus einer Mastanlage,
dort vegetierte sie schwerkrank vor sich hin.
Zusammen mit ihrem
Lebenspartner Jan Gerdes
kümmert sie sich in erster Linie um Kühe,
die nach vielen Jahren in der Landwirtschaft
eigentlich beim Schlachter gelandet wären.
Auf Hof Butenland können die Tiere
ihre letzten Jahre in Ruhe verbringen.
Wir haben hier das Essen vorbereitet für die
alten Damen und Herren aus der, ja,
Pflegeabteilung, kann man sagen.
Die leiden alle unter Arthrose
und schaffen es nicht mehr,
mit der großen Herde mitzulaufen.
Als Spinner werden sie von manch
einem Landwirt in der Gegend abgetan.
Doch ihr Projekt hat inzwischen
so viele Unterstützer,
dass sie mit den Spenden gut
für ihre 38 Rinder sorgen können.
Kuh Marieke ist ein Pflegefall.
Sie hat 12 Jahre lang im Stall gestanden,
Anbindehaltung heißt das im Fachjargon.
Mehr als 100.000 Liter Milch
hat sie in dieser Zeit gegeben.
Kuhpflegerin Mück findet es grausam,
dass in der Milchwirtschaft die Tiere
oft wie Maschinen behandelt werden.
Die Verbraucher wissen einfach zu wenig,
meint sie.
Es gibt eben so viele Märchen,
beispielsweise ‘ne Kuh
gibt eben immer Milch.
Dass die dafür erst mal
ein Kalb bekommen muss –
und in der heutigen Industriehaltung
ist es ja so,
sie wird ja auch noch zwangsbesamt,
sie kriegt das ja nicht freiwillig –,
dann wird ihr das Kalb weggenommen,
damit wir Milch trinken können.
Ihr Partner Jan Gerdes hatte den elterlichen
Hof zunächst als Biobauer weitergeführt,
bis er ganz aus der Landwirtschaft
ausgestiegen ist.
Andere Landwirte kritisieren ihn dafür:
Sie müssten hart arbeiten,
während er doch nur
Spenden einsammeln würde.
Doch das lässt er nicht gelten.
Ohne EU-Agrarsubventionen
würde eigentlich weit und breit
kaum noch ein Bauer zurechtkommen.
In meinen Augen sind das ja auch Spenden,
die vom Staat kommen.
Und da muss der Steuerzahler –
der muss sozusagen zwangsweise das Geld
zur Verfügung stellen,
und die Spenden, die wir bekommen,
sind ja absolut freiwillig.
Die tägliche Schlacht am kalten Heu-Büfett.
Ihre Rinder zeigen Gefühle
wie Freude und Trauer, sagt das Paar.
Die Tiere leben im Familienverbund,
streiten sich und schließen Freundschaften.
Die Herde kann sich auf rund 20 Hektar
Weideland frei bewegen.
Das Projekt soll nachdenklich machen.
Das andere ist aber auch sicher,
dass wir nicht mit dem Zeigefinger kommen,
dass wir nicht sagen:
‚Du bist böse, weil du das und das machst‘ –
oder dass wir blutige Bilder
aus dem Schlachthof zeigen,
sondern dass wir das mit Humor machen,
also, dass ich einfach
positiv versuche zu vermitteln,
wie toll Rinder sind, wie schön sie sind,
dass man lustige Dinge mit ihnen erlebt –
so wie jetzt.
War klar, danke.
Ein Butenländer hat es Karin Mück
besonders angetan: Ole.
Als Kalb musste er mit einem Zirkus
durch die Lande ziehen,
bis das Veterinäramt eingeschritten ist.
Statt zum Schlachthof kam
der junge Ochse nach Butenland.
Und hier bekommt er nun
regelmäßig seine Kuscheleinheiten,
ohne dafür Kunststücke zeigen zu müssen.